[Musique]
on va tout de suite accueillir la recrue
de la nouvelle la nouvelle recrue de
tous c'est à dire qu'elle va faire
partie de l'équipe elle va faire partie
de l'équipe l'année prochaine et ses
travaux dans le domaine de la télévision
en tant que productrice peut-être pas
productrice une journaliste non halima
crise et non oui on la connaît oui on la
connaît
oui le batteur est ce que ce n'est pas
un membre de la famille de quelqu'un
mais qui est ce par quoi est ce que
c'est un membre de la famille de
quelques années je veux savoir si elle a
un fils oui c'est patoche non à une fin
à tout non c'est pas ça commence pas à
la blonde là et non agréé
hélas l import-export quelqu'un tout la
tasse et un retour non parce que la
connaît oui c'est parce qu'elle est au
chômage
quoi sa femme non la femme de qui des
mages amano
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un amour
oui
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais juste pour les
téléspectateurs que tu présentes parce
que ce n'est pas seulement la femme de
benjamin castaldi aurait une heymans
professionnels de la télévision puisque
tu vas y dis nous tout ce que tu as fait
parce que ça n'est pas banal
déjà je voulais arriver avec les
lunettes elle se sont cassés en route
pour être plus sérieuses mais bon elle
se sont cassés en outre avéré bon dos ta
femme dans l'oreillette a été raté
j'assure la quatrième c'est hyper
aprilia 3e pas la seconde à la quatrième
l'avant dernier
[Applaudissements]
alors la raison derrière pas pour à la
pêche aux ouïes alors héros racontez
nous touche et je les fais parce que
pour les téléspectateurs
et bah écoutes je suis la femme donc de
benjamin donc la quatrième ça je viens
de le dire et j'ai été pendant dix ans à
directrice des castings endemol c'est ça
pour secret story
tout à fait donc j'ai fait les dix
saisons de secret' l'amour est aveugle
c'est une des grandes casteuse voilà de
paris et de france voilà aurore qui m'a
recruté
camille combal castaldi aussi dans cette
émission vous la connaissez grâce à la
caméra cachée de la grande race
raz-de-marée voilà benjamin voilà et
enfin quand ce qu'ils avaient piégé donc
le père de benjamin castaldi regarder
tout ça pour mesurer ces bons ne pas
pleurer quand même vous avez votre fils
l'a 26
conan de tentes donc quand je pense à
ces [ __ ] dalo
m
et derrière quelque chose benjamin était
au courant qu'elle allait venir
puisqu'on en a parlé tous les deux mais
c'est pas qu'ils allaient tenir
aujourd'hui voilà surprise projet la
zone grise c'est un jeu là ils pensaient
que j'étais en train de faire des boules
et de frites et de la sauce tomate à la
maison et voilà et ben voilà il est bien
content de l'avoir suis très content
merci et bachelot ou pas eu le taxi pour
l'europe à l'est
non